[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans l'émission point
de vue je vous présente les deux invités
qui ont accepté d'y participer Laurent
Joffrin bonjour bonjour vous avez été
patron des rédactions de libération et
de l'Obs et vous êtes aujourd'hui le
fondateur du mouvement engageons-nous
absolument et votre dernier livre
s'intitulait anti Macron il est paru
chez Stock en septembre 2020 face à vous
Jean-Christophe buisson bonsoir vous
êtes directeur adjoint du Figaro
Magazine
accessoirement mon patron du coup vous
animez l'émission historiquement chose
sur Histoire TV et votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule Napoléon l'esprit des lieux
il est paru en octobre 2020 chez Michel
Lafont c'est très bien c'est très bon
livre voilà on peut le mettre sur la
bande
on ne coupera pas au montage en plus
cette ce compliment alors trois thèmes
ont retenu notre notre attention
aujourd'hui la première question qu'on
vous pose c'est Emmanuel Macron a-t-il
eu raison de ne pas reconfiner en
février deuxième question Xavier
Bertrand a-t-il eu raison de se déclarer
candidat à la présidentielle de 2022 de
2022 sito et enfin une troisième
question si on a un peu de temps mais je
pense qu'on le prendra parce que nous
avons deux éminents commentateurs
sportifs aujourd'hui le 15 de France
peut-il gagner le tournoi des 6 nations
ce soir alors on commence tout de suite
avec le premier thème Emmanuel Macron
a-t-il eu raison de ne pas reconfiner en
février chaque jour non confiné est un
jour gagné dit le gouvernement les
médecins d'isol l'inverse que c'est un
jour de perdu Emmanuel Macron en marge
du sommet européen est revenu hier sur
sa décision de ne pas reconfiner le pays
en février en l'écoute
est-ce que le 29 janvier nous aurions dû
confiner le pays comme certains le
disaient comme des modèles montraient
que nous allions flamber en février
écoutez nous l'avons collectivement nous
en avons fait l'expérience collective
réelle non et donc je peux vous le dire
nous avons eu raison de ne pas confiner
la France à la fin du mois de janvier
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu l'explosion qui
était prévu par tous les modèles donc je
peux vous affirmer là cette fois-ci que
je n'ai aucun mea culpa à faire ni aucun
remord ni aucun constat d'échec nous
avons eu raison de le faire
on reviendra sur la notion de mea culpa
un peu plus tard mais l'orange infra je
voudrais avoir vous votre avis vous
rangez dans quelle catégorie ce qui a
des enfermiste et les autres ou ceux qui
approuvent le chef de l'État de ne pas
avoir confiné reconfiner en février ou
ceux qui le désapprouvent je pense qu'il
a eu raison de tenter ce pari
parce que
les inconvénients ou même les malheurs
causés par le confinement sont énormes
c'est vrai ça et puis alors sur le plan
un peu plus cynique c'est terrible à
dire mais je crois que l'opinion la
population s'habitue petit à petit au
décompte des morts
et plus que il y a 6 mois et du coup
mettent en balance toutes les
contraintes qu'on leur impose et les
pertes humaines que la population subit
et les pertes humaines ont un peu moins
de poids qu'elles avaient auparavant et
Jean-Christophe buisson pour vous c'est
une semaine
chaque semaine non confiné est une
semaine gagnée ou une semaine perdue je
sais pas si c'est le par ce biais là
qu'on peut raisonner je pense que
sanitairement
il avait il a peut-être tort mais on le
saura dans un mois ou dans deux mois
peut-être que le décalage lorsqu'il se
réjouit que ça n'est pas flambé en
février ça a l'air de commencer à
flamber sérieusement fin mars donc il y
a peut-être un décalage d'un mois donc
il a peut-être un peu tort de s'emballer
en disant j'ai eu raison j'ai raison
ce qui est sûr c'est que
je pense que il a tenu compte à la fois
de ce que dit sous-entend l'orange au
frein c'est-à-dire la situation
psychologique sociale de beaucoup de
Français
et l'opinion publique n'était pas prête
en janvier un confinement un
reconfinement je pense qu'il a il a
enfin j'interprète mais je pense il
s'est dit si je reconfigne une explosion
les gens étaient prêts au premier
confinement évidemment au deuxième un
petit peu qui était déjà moins mais là
là ils étaient pas prêts c'était pas
possible il s'est dit ça il s'est dit je
vais on va dans un mur donc je fais ce
pari comme dit pas totalement idiot ni
Laurent Joffrin ni le Paris puisque il
partait de l'idée que à quoi bon
confinement si on n'a pas les vaccins à
temps pour permettre le déconfinement
encore une fois confiner c'est une chose
dès qu'on finit en est une autre on a
subi la mer expérience l'été dernier
donc si on confine des janvier mais que
on n'a pas de vaccin avant avril de
toute façon on peut pas déconfiner tant
qu'il y a pas les vaccins puisque
maintenant on a compris que la seule
solution pour sortir de de cette peste
là c'est le vaccin donc c'est
effectivement de ce point de vue là
quand même des jours des jours de gagner
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
économique et évidemment d'un point de
vue social d'un point de vue
psychologique pour à l'école encore une
fois on a on a préféré ne pas fermer les
écoles pour pour pas recréer les
tensions alors peut-être qu'on va devoir
le faire donc je pense que je suis assez
d'accord avec Laurent Geoffrin pour pour
des raisons qui sont pas forcément des
sanitaire pur médical pur il a eu raison
de tenter ce pari mais ça veut pas dire
exactement je reviens sur cette idée de
Paris est-ce que alors l'Élysée ne l'a
jamais dit ce mot de Paris mais il est
accrédité par vous et finalement repris
par tout le monde est-ce que c'est pas
dangereux pour l'Elysée de de laisser
comme ça ce mot pari parce que si c'est
perdu pour le coup il va lui dire
très très mauvais d'abord sur le plan
sanitaire parce que si jamais il
explosion comme les modèles semblait le
dire parce que il faut regarder les
modèles on dit toujours ils seront alors
oui et non quand on compare la courbe
des prévisions et la courbe réelle on
s'aperçoit que quand les scientifiques
disent que ça va monter ça monte quand
ils disent ça va aller mieux polémique
parce que dans son intervention il dit
les modèles me disaient sur février et
en fait les scientifiques non les
modèles prévoyaient ce que montre cette
comparaison que tout le monde devrait
faire il faut regarder ce qu'il prévoit
les gens puis ce qui s'est passé le
profil est le même et parfois il est
décalé
exploser en février en fait c'est en
avril et c'est bon c'est difficile à
prévoir ce sont des modèles c'est comme
le modèle économique c'est même moins
fiable à mon avis que les modèles
économiques parce que les comportements
des gens est plus difficile à anticiper
et donc il a eu raison d'essayer en se
disant bon si jamais j'arrive à faire
vacciner suffisamment de gens je
pourrais ne pas reconfiner donc du coup
on pourra lui dire parce que l'histoire
de la vaccination les gens euh
beaucoup de gens ne saisissent pas bien
ça à ce que une fois qu'on aura vacciné
les gens à risque les gens âgés et les
gens qui ont une autre maladie
normalement il y a plus d'embouteillages
d'engorgement des hôpitaux logiquement
alors les on a posé la question sur
Twitter Emmanuel Macron a-t-il eu raison
de ne pas reconfiner fin janvier et les
internautes sont assez d'accord avec
vous oui à 58%
pense qu'il a eu raison
vol pas eu 34 nous dit je pense qu'il a
bien fait de ne pas confiner car
l'économie est en bas ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure et beaucoup ne respectent
pas ils ne veulent pas et Gaëtan nous
dit le confinement étant inutile il
augmente le taux de contamination par
les restrictions transports en commun
bondés
les pays qui ont confiné comme comme
l'Allemagne et ils sont dans une depuis
le début d'année ils sont dans une
situation pire que la nôtre alors
peut-être encore une fois faire de
décalage on va rattraper ce désastre
dans les semaines qui viennent mais
aujourd'hui voilà depuis le début
janvier date à laquelle l'Allemagne est
confiné est dur il y a eu plus de morts
en Allemagne que en France qui n'a pas
reconfiné fait des couvre-feu etc donc
c'est ça qu'il faut en Angleterre au
Royaume-Uni de la même façon alors je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur un autre
aspect de l'intervention de d'Emmanuel
Macron qui refuse lui pour le coup de
faire un mea culpa alors qu'on a vu la
veille Angela Merkel qui elle faisait
non seulement un mea culpa mais
reconnaissait une erreur je vous propose
d'écouter la chanceler allemande c'était
le 24 mars
alors en ne faisant pas de mea culpa
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron a
politiquement raison médiatiquement tort
ou l'inverse
politiquement immédiatement ah oui mais
quand on voit l'impact que
l'impact que cette que ces excuses qu'a
faites en guerre Angela Merkel a eu
c'est extraordinaire c'est c'est
demander pardon pour quelques pour une
faute qui est quand même pas qui est pas
très larme qui est reconnu immédiatement
c'est peut-être ça la différence ce que
je crains c'est que à force de commettre
des erreurs ayant eu c'est là où il est
quand même indéfendable Emmanuel Macron
a dire je n'ai aucun remord mais ni sur
les masses ni sur les tests quoi que ce
soit on lui parle pas que de la section
il aurait pu dire j'ai pu me tromper
dans le passé mais sur ce coup là je ne
me trompe pas là même pas c'est grosso
je circulais il y a rien à voir j'ai
raison circuler il y a rien à voir et ça
je pense que c'est ce qui peut être
considéré comme de l'arrogance ça passe
de moins en moins et ça passera d'autant
moins si son pari n'est pas gagné
l'infaillibilité du président de la 5ème
république
[Musique]
européens ne sont pas des monarchies
républicaines ouais c'est ça ce sont des
monarchies parfois mais
les rois demandés pardon ça peut arriver
oui etc mais oui Louis XIV avait demandé
pardon mais sur son lit
donc on va attendre
il a encore le temps j'espère aussi
c'est peut-être la dimension oublions
pas qui ont gagné c'est un parti
chrétien démocrate la culpabilité
chrétienne elle est fille de pasteur
plus assumé dans quelqu'un qui se dit
chrétient que Emmanuel Macron qui a ma
connaissance ne se dit pas
forts commises avant moi mais là il
pense qu'il s'est pas trompé donc
mais quand ils se trompe il s'excuse pas
non plus donc c'est une doctrine
on va voir si Xavier omertrand s'est
trompé ou pas en tout cas il a franchi
le Rubicon et annoncé dans le point
qu'il sera candidat il utilise bien le
futur en 2022 je vous propose d'écouter
sa déclaration
je serai candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 je le fais par
deux voix parce que j'estime qu'au
moment où nous sommes le choix ce sera
entre le déclin et le redressement de
mon pays je veux conduire leur
dressement de mon pays et je vous
réconcilier les Français
alors évidemment ces opposants
immédiatement réagissent je vous propose
d'écouter parmi eux Adrien catenins
député la France insoumise du Nord il
était sur Public Sénat
l'ambition qu'il a pour les hauts de
France aujourd'hui c'est rien d'autre
que simplement s'en servir comme vous
l'avez dit d'un marche-pied vers la
présidentielle et ça très franchement du
point de vue des citoyennes des citoyens
des Hauts-de-France je pense qu'il voit
bien là que le candidat à la Régionale
vous avez Bertrand sera a priori très
peu de temps soucieux de la région une
fois élu s'il était alors Laurent c'est
une bonne initiative de la part de
Xavier Bertrand il fallait qu'il le
fasse maintenant je crois qu'il l'a fait
exactement pour à cause de ce que dit
quatre nains c'est à dire que il craint
que les régionales soient reportés et
donc le marche-pied fasse défaut avec
ses armes le marche-pied on parle à
quatre nains c'est à dire gagner les
élections dans les hauts de France donc
ça lui permettait de se propulser
et comme il risque de pas y en avoir
ou qu'elle sera reporté
je vais y aller l'autre problème c'est
qu'il veut empêcher les primaires de se
mettre en place on va y venir
effectivement craint que le parti LR
parce que il n'y est plus aux donc il
craque le parti LR façon son propre
processus de désignation et qu'il est en
face de lui quelqu'un donc il essaye de
tuer le match est-ce qu'il va y arriver
c'est une autre affaire j'enregistre de
Buisson c'est c'est la bonne période les
Français ont la tête à la dans la
présidentielle là non mais je pense pas
qu'ils résonne comme ça et il résonne il
a besoin de se positionner au centre au
centre d'un jeu qui s'annonce à avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de candidats je
parle du jeu que ce soit Valérie
Pécresse que ce soit Bruno Retailleau
que ce soit peut-être François Baroin
qui soit peut-être Michel Barnier il y a
quand même beaucoup de monde dans
l'écurie droite centre droite centre
droit pardon et on se positionnant dès
maintenant il force un peu le destin
parce qu'il a compris qu'au sein des
républicains auxquels il n'appartient
plus l'idée c'est que s'il y a quand
même un candidat qui s'est dégagé ça
sera naturellement lui et s'il prend
beaucoup d'avance dans les semaines qui
viennent parce qu'il va faire beaucoup
de médias parce qu'on va beaucoup parler
de lui puisqu'il est candidat avéré
c'est un pari si là 3 4 5 6 points
d'avance sur un autre candidat virtuel
de droite ça sera difficile de se passer
de lui et par ailleurs il se couvre d'un
autre côté si je puis dire en se
positionnant si jamais il voulait se
rallier Emmanuel Macron comme peut-être
un premier ministre d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est Emmanuel Macron et élu donc il
gagne un peu sur ces deux tableaux là le
seul schéma malsain pour lui ça serait
qu'effectivement une décolle pas du tout
dans les sondages que Valérie Pécresse
reste à un ou deux points derrière lui
que Bruno Retailleau soit pas loin que
François Baroin finalement se déclare et
qu'il passe pour un des diviseurs si
nous ça rallie pas et notre candidature
son idée aussi c'est je suis antenne
donc c'est les autres qui se relient à
moi mais vous avez raison que arrivé à
ce moment-là en ce moment alors qu'on
est vraiment obnubilé par la par la
crise par la pandémie ça il y a une
petite dissonance mais en même temps ça
fait un an qu'on est obnubilé par la
pandémie donc ce qui est étonnant
l'orange refrain c'est vous avez lu
l'interview j'imagine dans le point il
ne parle pas du tout du covid on a
beaucoup de propositions le sujet n'est
pas abordé c'est ça me dérange pas qu'il
en parle pas franchement pourquoi parce
que on passe notre vie encore
bon vous mais sa ligne est assez clair
sécurité
beaucoup plus ferme en matière de
sécurité et l'immigration et sociale
c'est les deux
propositions assez fermes aussi sur la
retraite
on a entendu qu'il pouvait discuter
Arnaud Montebourg était sensible
son deuxième calcul c'est de se dire si
j'arrive à avoir un
des sondages favorables dans le cadre
d'une campagne les gens de gauche
des gens de gauche peuvent se dire notre
candidat alors on fait des hypothèses
notre candidat n'est pas au niveau il
n'a aucune chance ou elle a aucune
chance ça dépend qui c'est et donc comme
j'aime pas Macron qui nous a trahi
Macron tout sauf Macron et j'aime pas le
Pen encore moins donc finalement
Bertrand devient assez logique et ça
vous paraît crédible vous qui êtes
maintenant un peu dans de la partie
puisque ça ce mécanisme là a fait
l'élection de d'Emmanuel Macron c'est à
dire que il y a des gens des socialistes
des électeurs socialistes de gauche du
centre gauche qui se sont dit Hamon il
n'a aucune chance en plus sa proposition
ça tient pas la route enfin bref et donc
je vote Macron pour empêcher Fillon au
premier tour et pour empêcher le Pen au
deuxième et comme ça que Macron était
élu mais que si les originales ont quand
même lieu les gens de gauche dont vous
parlait qui pourrait être ils sont
réunis sous la même manière si je
m'abuse
en allant en élan en prenant langue avec
des gens comme Arnaud Montebourg en
donnant l'impression que justement il
peut être un recours pour certaines
gauches il se met peut-être à dos un
certain électorat de à droite qui lui
manquera lors de la espèce de grande
triangulaire qui s'annonce dans les
hauts de France entre la gauche unie du
PS à la France insoumise le
rassemblement national qui en plus n'est
plus représenté par Marine Le Pen mais
Sébastien Chenu donc c'est quand même un
impact sans doute moins en fait en
termes de notoriété et puis et puis lui
qui était au centre du jeu donc c'est
c'est moins facile je pense donc un
petit risque quand même de vite en
besogne je trouve qu'on parle avec les
hommes politiques ça arrive et donc il
racontait que en zoom il a fait en 90
et il racontait qu'il avait fait trois
fois le tour de la terre dans une
camionnette mais pas de la Terre mais
dans les hauts de France ah oui il passe
sa vie aller de village village et de
ville en ville etc
il fait que ça c'est le rôle d'un
président trois fois
dans les hauts de France juste un trans
donc ils connaissent la région Parker
c'est ça que je pense qu'il a connu
tout le monde
tous les
et donc il pense qu'il serait réélu
enfin droit de social
antimigration sécurité ça fait ça fait
un peu Chirac années 80
et le mouvement engageons-nous c'est
peut être sensible à la démarche de
Xavier ah non non
[Rires]
on est du camp de la gauche quoi donc on
est on est on est de la gauche
social-démocrate républicaine
ouverte tolérante et tout ce qu'on veut
mais bon là jusqu'à Xavier Bertrand
j'ai rien contre Bertrand mais ils sont
droites nous on est de gauche
alors on a posé la question pareille sur
Twitter Xavier Bertrand a-t-il eu raison
de déclarer sa candidature à la
présidentielle sitôt et bien là la
réponse est assez claire aussi non à 66%
Gaëtan nous dit n'a aucune chance de
gagner quoi que ce soit il pouvait même
le faire l'année dernière l'année
dernière ça n'aurait rien changé bon ça
c'est assez radical babino dit je
toujours pas ce qui différencie Xavier
Bertrand d'Emmanuel Macron sur le
positionnement politique qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspire Jeanne buisson ça
m'inspire que comme Emmanuel Macron
donne l'impression en ce moment d'aller
de plus en plus vers le régalien vers la
sécurité c'est plutôt Macron qui sera
proche de Bertrand qui s'est quand même
lui-même un peu et peut-être éloigné du
noyau nucléaire qui de la droite dont il
se rapproche donc tout le monde se
droitise d'une certaine manière je pense
que Laurent Joffrin
député de voir ça mais c'est tout le
monde se gratise parce que la société se
gratise bien sûr enfin il me semble que
c'est l'écho les hommes politiques comme
gavés Bertrand il y a deux ans c'était
le grand méchant mou aujourd'hui il
faudrait que c'est un discours beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus ferme donc parce
qu'il a écouté l'opinion et peut-être
parce qu'il a fait ses 120000 km et que
son électorat enfin l'électorat
potentiel de France donne l'impression
que
voilà c'est de baratin de maintenant il
faut prendre des un peu plus de fermeté
dans la et je pense que Emmanuel Macron
suit aussi cette tendance elle se
gratise la société à cause de la réalité
les attentats terroristes l'insécurité
des crimes qu'on voit à la télévision
qui sont montrés avec beaucoup de
complaisance parfois c'est un fait il
n'invente pas les crimes qui se
déroulent et donc c'est difficile pour
le pour les gens de gauche c'est vrai et
puis il faut ajouter que il y a une
partie de la gauche qui s'ingénit a
porté sur un plateau à la droite des
arguments je pense pour ne pas les
nommer les militants de syndicat
étudiants U9 et lunettes et voilà cette
petite scission là de Grenoble
comment voulez-vous qu'on c'est
indéfendable leur truc actuellement
indéfendable donc on était obligé de
condamner l'UNEF qui était
[Musique]
le grand syndicat de la gauche et qui a
formé par qui a formé tous les
générations
en déséquilibre
parce que nous nous on condamne
évidemment le fait de mettre des profs
au pyloris sous prétexte qu'ils ont été
méfiants avec la notion d'islamophobie
on l'est aussi méfiant donc on piqué de
tenir une gauche républicaine mais c'est
vrai que quand on a comme c'est comme
une famille un cousin il fait que des
bêtises donc ça finit par gênant pour la
famille
sur le principe de la primaire donc
Xavier Bertrand dit non moi je je fais
comme finalement le général de Gaulle un
homme un peuple et je me présente
c'est une mauvaise solution la primaire
vous trouvez pour que ce soit pour la
droite ou à gauche mais pour
sélectionner un candidat c'est pas les
mêmes électeurs c'est ça le problème
c'est démocratique et quand il y a pas
un candidat qui se détache des autres
c'est ça il faut bien trouver un moyen
de départager et à moins qu'il se
présente tous mais à ce moment-là vous
êtes sûrs
mais l'ennui c'est que c'est pas du tout
le même le même correctoral c'est des
gens
durs motiver et qui vont qui vont élire
Fillon alors que il est beaucoup plus à
droite que la moyenne des électeurs qui
vont voter aux élections pas aux
primaires et c'est un peu pareil à
gauche ils ont mis un nom qui était
excentré par rapport mais avant ils
avaient choisi François Hollande oui
mais là
avait emporté donc qu'est-ce qui a
changé d'ailleurs entre les deux le
bilan de l'eau
non je pense non je pense que Hollande
dans ces sondages étaient devant et donc
les gens ont les gens y compris ils
courent vers la victoire ce que vous
voulez dire y compris les gens de la
primaire
au moins lui celui qui nous fait gagner
il a plus de chance de gagner mais ça
c'est pas du tout vérifier avec cela ils
avaient amont et valse à la fois d'après
les gens de gauche donc les deux
buisson vous avez Bertrand se méfie des
sarkozytes il a une petite phrase dans
dans cette interview où on voit bien
qu'il a un doute sur ce que pourrait
faire Nicolas Sarkozy si c'était lui le
candidat il a raison de se méfier des
sarkozymes dans la perspective de 2022
je sais pas s'il est sarkozymes ou
Nicolas Sarkozy ont déjà choisi leur
candidat dans ce dans ce dans ce schéma
dans ce panorama actuel parce que le
panorama qu'on voit aujourd'hui n'est
pas celui qui sera en septembre 2020
ou les choses vont vraiment s'accélérer
c'est là où Christian Jacob décidera que
là oui effectivement il y a un candidat
ou pas de candidat on fait des primaires
encore une fois moi je la petite musique
François Baroin il faut quand même
l'entendre parce qu'elle est en train de
monter gentiment et il est vraiment sur
le même créneau que vous avez Bertrand
et je pense que les sarkozymes pensent
un peu aussi peut-être à François Baroin
lorsqu'il déploie pas le tapis rouge
sous les pieds de Xavier Bertrand mais
rien ne nous dit que
à la fin faute de candidats qui leur
plaît plus que Xavier Bertrand une chose
avait Bertrand mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils vont pas l'aider dans ça voilà
dans sa précédente problème ça c'est une
certitude ce qu'il a besoin d'être aidé
par les sarkozymes dans sa campagne
je sais pas
si la question se pose c'est que Nicolas
Sarkozy dans une interview figurine
mais le Figaro a fait un autre article
parce que je suis un lecteur assise
et donc cet article disait que il y a
beaucoup de gens de chez Macron qui sont
j'ai une alliance avec des gens de
droite une partie de la droite et puis
Estrosi qui le dit ouvertement
donc ça c'est redoutable pour Bertrand
ça c'est vrai ça c'est une sorte du coup
il peut être pris en tenaille à la fois
par Emmanuel Macron absolument Nicolas
Sarkozy sauf si ce radium
chardon bleu n'est pas totalement
d'accord avec vous il était Macron
compatible et il n'est pas certain qu'il
ne fasse pas un calcul en fait il est
d'accord avec vous pour avoir un poste
en négation avec Macron non en fait il
est complètement d'accord avec vous
Chardon Bleu merci chardon il a quitté
Hélène j'espère que les dirigeants LR ne
vont pas en faire leur candidat voilà ça
c'est effectivement un autre sujet qu'on
pourra aborder plus tard c'est de savoir
qu'est-ce que l'élève vont choisir
Chardon Bleu c'était par rapport à
l'Écosse et l'équipe de France je pense
que ça nous fait une excellente
transition ma foi il nous reste quand
même un peu de temps pour pour évoquer
ce thème si vous êtes d'accord mais moi
je suis d'accord avec je suis pas
d'accord avec vous mais cette
politiquement mais je suis d'accord
alors voilà on a effectivement un match
ce soir c'était pas prévu c'est
finalement grâce au à cause du covid qui
les programmé ce soir c'est un Français
cosse
et avec une mission pour le 15 de France
si elle veut gagner le tournoi des
signations il faut qu'elle mette quatre
essais et 21 points d'écart avec les
cosses alors la question elle est simple
Jean-Christophe buisson la réponse peut
être moi est-ce que c'est jouable c'est
jouable parce qu'il y a une dynamique
extraordinaire dans cette équipe de
France une dynamique interne sportive
professionnelle grâce à leur victoire
sur le Pays de Galles je crois qu'on est
passé 3e à la française au classement de
mondial et puis il y a une dynamique je
pense qu'ils sentent comme l'équipe de
France en 98 santé il dynamique en
France des Français qui sont derrière
cette équipe on est tellement en manque
de d'émotion collective et pour cause on
a plus de réunions collective mais même
au sein des réactions des journaux et là
on a senti même contre l'Angleterre on a
perdu de justesse et contre le pays de
Galles un mouvement un mouvement
collectif et je pense que les joueurs
ressentent ça de manière presque
tellurique que il y a la France derrière
quoi il y a pas d'événements sportifs
avant l'Euro dans trois mois il y en a
pas eu beaucoup du coup cet hiver et je
pense qu'il portait par ça ça peut
rajouter les points qui manqueraient
objectivement sur un franc Écosse qui en
temps normal devrait se concluer par une
victoire de la France de quelques points
là il y a un enjeu gigantesque et il
sentent je pense le pays derrière eux et
ils sentent que le la France a besoin de
cette victoire bonifiée pour sortir un
peu la tête de l'eau de cette épidémie
alors je ferai je sais pas si vous êtes
un amateur
mais
le fait que voilà il y a une bouffée
d'optimisme dans le sentiment quelque
chose en plus
quiconque a vu le match France Gall se
dit ils ont quand même des ressources
morales considérables parce que ils ont
réussi à 4 minutes de la fin il y avait
10 points d'écart en faveur de Gallois
et ils ont gagné dans les dans les
prolongations sur
[Musique]
je suis pas encore une fois un
spécialiste mais quand on voit la balle
circuler et la manière dont ils ont
réussi à mettre l'essai à la fin c'est
c'est une longue une longue offensive
extrêmement acharnée et en même temps
talentueuse avec les alliés à la fin et
c'est formidable et je trouve que ils
peuvent très bien faire le chaos assez
vite et ensuite le score devient flop
devient l'Écosse à un enjeu aussi elle
peut finir deuxième du tournoi gagnant
c'est pas l'Italie en face donc il y
aura vraiment il y aura vraiment un
combat il y aura vraiment un ils ont
battu l'Angleterre à tous les Can-Am ce
qui était pas arrivé depuis très
longtemps donc ils sont assez remontés
et donc il sentent au-delà de cette nuit
les gens individuellement chez eux qui
se regroupent collectivement pour les
c'est ça que je trouve extraordinaire
au-delà de l'aspect sportif qui est qui
est magnifique et qui préfigure
peut-être une coupe du monde en France
dans deux ans merveilleuse mais avec en
plus en majeur France Nouvelle-Zélande
donc en plus en finale on espère aussi
donc c'est assez moi c'est ça qui me qui
me fascine dans ces dans cette histoire
c'est moyen de monde dans le stade plus
les gens sont individualisés plus on a
besoin d'un moment
[Musique]
alors les internautes sont d'accord avec
nous si je vous ai pas besoin
80 % toutes les différences alors la
question c'est le 15 de France peut-il
gagner ce soir donc oui à 80 %. le
problème c'est que voilà il y a il faut
mettre 4 essais et un écart assez
important donc ça c'est pas si simple on
peut gagner le match nous dit arumat
mais le tournoi ce sera une autre paire
de manches voilà en tout cas on peut
s'attendre à un match avec des
intentions de jeux des deux équipes
c'est vrai que c'est les deux équipes
les plus joueuses et on va donner le mot
de la fin à Baptiste qui a réussi à
regrouper les deux thèmes qu'on vient
d'aborder en disant le 15 de France a
carrément plus de chance que Xavier
Bertrand voilà merci de ce de ce mot de
la fin bon match bonne soirée et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]